>> WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW.
FOX NEWS WITNESSING MORE THAN
500 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER THIS MORNING
ALONE INCLUDING THIS HUGE SINGLE
GROUP OF 290.
DOZEN OF MIGRANTS ARRIVED FROM
TEXAS THIS MORNING AS THE SURGE
ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER FORCES
FED UP GOVERNORS TO SEND THEM
NORTH.
HERE IS ANOTHER PROBLEM
DEVELOPING FROM THOSE BUSES.
THE MIGRANTS IN THE COUNTRY
LEGALLY THREATENING TO CALL THE
COPS FOR HELP.
THE NEW YORK POST REPORTING
"SOME OF THE PASSENGERS ON THE
NEW YORK ROUND BUS BECAME UPSET
WHEN THE DRIVER ANNOUNCED A
CHANGE IN THE ITINERARY PLEADING
FOR HOURS TO MAKE THE PLAN TO
STOP.
MANY HAD PLANS TO MEET
RELATIVES.
THE STATE OF TEXAS GAVE THEM
ENVELOPES.
THE BUSTED STOP IN CHATTANOOGA.
I WAS LOOKING TODAY, GETTING
PREPARED FOR THIS.
HOW WE USED TO DEAL WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
WHEN THE COUNTRY BEGAN, THE
ASSUMPTION WAS THAT THE STATE
GOVERNMENTS WOULD POLICE THEIR
INTERNAL TERRITORY AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAD ALMOST NO
TERRITORY OVER THIS WHATSOEVER.
>> I JUST WONDER WHAT HAPPENED.
YOU TAKE SOMETHING THAT IS A
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AND THEN IT
GOES OFF THE RAILS AND THEY TAKE
THE POSITION IN WASHINGTON THAT
THE STATES CAN'T DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
IS THIS A FEDERAL STATE PROBLEM?
OR IS IT RUNNING AMOK?
>> YOU SEE IT IN A CERTAIN WAY.
ACTORS INVOLVED AND WHAT THAT IS
CLEARLY, THIS HAS BEEN A PROBLEM
FOR THE LAST 50 YEARS.
THIS HAS BEEN RANGING FROM
GOVERNOR AND THEN PRESIDENT
REAGAN AND THE PROMISES TO BUILD
A WALL AND SECURE THE SOUTHERN
BORDER WHICH NEVER OCCURRED.
YOU SEE THIS GAME BACK AND FORTH
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENTS.
THEY KNOW THAT THIS HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR A LONG TIME.
THERE IS A AN INTEREST AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL WHEN IT COMES TO
REDISTRICTING HOW YOU GET POWER.
YES, VOTING, THE NATURE OF THE
WORKER FRAMEWORK, WAGES.
HAS AMERICA, WE ARE A NATION OF
IMMIGRANTS.
THIS IS NOT FAR OFF FROM HOW WE
VIEW OURSELVES.
WHO WOULD NOT WANT TO COME HERE.
THE PROBLEM BECOMES IT GOES OFF
THE RAILS.
WHEN YOU HAVE A BUREAUCRACY SO
BIG IT DOES NOT KNOW HOW TO
HANDLE THIS.
REAL PEOPLES LIVES ARE AT RISK.
SOME VIEWED THE MIGRANTS AS
BEING CHILDREN SOMEHOW.
THESE ARE STRONG HEARTED PEOPLE.
LONGTIME CULTURES THAT THEY HAVE
TO FLEE THEIR OWN HOME WHICH IS
HORRIBLE.
THESE ARE NOT BABIES.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
WHITE.
THEY SPEAK A DIFFERENT LANGUAGE
AND THEY COME HERE AND OFTEN
THRIVE.
A CEILING OF KEEPING THOUSAND OF
VISUALS DOWN.
AMERICANS ARE BEING KEPT DOWN.
IT IS A FEDERAL ISSUE BECAUSE OF
FEDERAL INTEREST.
STATES OF COURSE AND BECOME
OVERWHELMED BECAUSE THE OTHER
EXISTING ECONOMIC PROBLEMS.
EVERYBODY LOSES IN THE MIGRANTS
GET PUSHED OFF TO THE SIDE AND
HARMED EVEN MORE.
SEX TRAFFICKING, DRUG
TRAFFICKING, THE COMMUNITIES, IF
THEY END UP HOMELESS.
>> TRYING TO STAY ON TOP OF THIS
IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RUNS
THIS, THE STATE HAS NOTHING TO
SAY.
I THINK THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING
FROM KATHY HOGLE.
GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK.
OKAY.
I JUST DID A TOUR OF UPSTATE NEW
YORK.
I WALK THE STREETS OF MANHATTAN.
I WALK THE STREETS OF ALBAN HE.
NOW IT IS ALL PEACHY.
>> STOP PAYING PEOPLE TO STAY
HOME.
I DISAGREE WITH YOU A LITTLE
BIT.
STRONG HEARTED PEOPLE.
SOME MAY NOT BE.
WE ARE NOT VETTING THE PEOPLE
THAT COME INTO THE COUNTRY.
GOOD PEOPLE, BAD PEOPLE.
SOME SHOULD GET IN, SOME SHOULD
NOT.
MY FRUSTRATION, MAYBE THIS GOES
TO YOUR QUESTION, YOU HAVE
STATES THAT HAVE NO CONTROL OVER
THE BORDER.
>> PAYING FOR THE SCHOOLS AND
HOSPITALS AND HOUSING FOR
MIGRANTS.
LIBERALS LOVE THIS POLICY.
JUST LIKE THEY WALK TO DEFUND
THE POLICE BUT NOT IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
THEY WANT TO LET CRIMINALS OUT
OF JAIL, BUT NOT IN THEIR
BACKYARD.
THEY HAVE POLICIES AND
PHILOSOPHIES.
GREAT FOR EVERYBODY ELSE, BUT
NOT THEMSELVES.
LET PEOPLE IN.
WE SHOULD LET THEM KNOW WHO THEY
ARE, ARE THEY GOING TO WORK OR
SUCK OFF THE SYSTEM.
>> THIS IS GOOD FOR OUR ECONOMY.
SO AT ON THIS ISSUE.
TAKING ON MAYOR ADAMS WHO CALLED
THIS A SANCTUARY STATE.
NOT WANTING THEM TO COME HERE.
AT LEAST THAT IS WHAT HE IS
SAYING RIGHT NOW.
I AGREE WITH YOU.
THE HELP WANTED AD.
IT IS NOT NECESSARILY BECAUSE WE
HAVE A LABOR PROBLEM.
THEY ARE GETTING THINGS LIKE IN
THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT.
IF THEY STAY HOME LONG ENOUGH
THE GOVERNMENT WILL HELP THEM
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE